[Music]
on this Friday night the deepening
humanitarian disaster in Gaza what
Palestinians are being forced to resort
to the Health crisis massively
overcrowded United Nations shelters have
become Havens to spread infectious
diseases as questions grow about what
Israel knew about hamas's October 7th
attack T the season for a covid case
Spike what doctors are recommending as
holiday parties ramp up it was a
dinosaur eat Dinosaur World back then
this was a unique and unusual Discovery
the fresh find in Alberta exciting
paleontologists around the globe and
Toronto's potential home run the
baseball superstar that has blue J fans
buzzing global national with faren Asser
reporting tonight gcha good evening and
thanks for joining us Israel has
Unleashed one of its largest strikes yet
on Hamas since the end of that
humanitarian pause one that's also
deepening the suffering in Gaza in
what's already being called an
apocalyptic situation by the un's human
rights commissioner a warning some of
the images in our coverage tonight are
distressing gaza's Hamas run Health
Ministry says more than 177,000
Palestinians have died since October 7th
more than 7,000 of them children doctors
without borderers said this week more
dead than wounded were arriving at the
al- AXA Hospital in southern Gaza Israel
also faces increased scrutiny not only
for the destruction in Gaza but for its
failures regarding hamas's attack on
October 7th we'll have more team
coverage tonight from London Washington
and Jerusalem for our top story we begin
with Crystal ganing on Israel's intense
assault in a punishing 24 hours Israeli
officials said Friday it destroyed 400
50 Hamas targets striking the small
densely populated Enclave by land air
and
sea the people who used to live here say
their homes were hit just after morning
prayers out of nowhere I just saw
everything falling on our heads says
this man I swear for me destruction and
death are one they're left to scour the
rubble salvaging what they can and have
to find somewhere to sleep the Union of
medical care and relief organizations
says the war must end civilian
population is suffering massively
overcrowded United Nation shelters have
become Havens to spread infectious
diseases including a hepatitis A
outbreak multiple menitis
outbreaks lice skin infections and
multiple diarrhea illness
outbreaks multiple humanitarian agencies
say they're running out of words to to
express the devastation their teams are
witnessing in Gaza action against
hungers as people are resorting to
digging holes in the sand for toilets
because there aren't enough facilities
save the children say people are
reporting eating just once a day if at
all Oxfam says no number of Aid trucks
will be able to meet the needs their
policy advisor said we're not going to
count the
crumbs I went through hell at the
Crossing to get two Bott of water for my
children says this father of six I am a
grownup married man I had a job in
everything in Gaza City this mother who
fled to Rafa from the north is worried
about her daughter she says she has a
fever but they have no medicine they
have
nothing 1.8 million people are
reportedly displaced in Gaza an
estimated 40% of the civilian
infrastructure has been destroyed
Israel's Defense Forces say they are
finding Hamas hideouts and cashes of
weapons in residential buildings schools
as well as mosques Neu crystal ganing in
London thanks Crystal Israel's Envoy to
the United Nations is thanking US
President Joe Biden tonight after the US
blocked a security Council resolution
that would have called for an immediate
humanitarian ceasefire in Gaza far
Nasser joins us with how it all unfolded
far through 13 member countries in
including permanent members China Russia
and France all voted in favor of the
draft resolution put forward by the
United Arab Emirates demanding an
immediate ceasefire diplomatically
isolating Washington which backed its
Ally Israel with a veto the US
ambassador to the UN Robert Woods said
the text in the resolution was divorced
from reality we do not support calls for
an immediate
ceasefire this would only plant the
seeds for the next War because Hamas has
no desire to see a durable peace to see
a two-state
solution Britain was the only country
that abstained from the vote its
Ambassador saying calling for a
ceasefire ignores the fact that Hamas
has committed acts of Terror the vote
has really been a test of the un's
authority article 99 is one of the UN
secretary General's most powerful tools
and it's rarely been used it's like a
red flag system that empowers the
Secretary General to inform the Council
of M matters that threaten International
Peace and security Antonio Gutierrez
used it for the first time in his tenure
this week he says 130 un staff have been
killed in Israel's war against Hamas
this is the largest single loss of life
in the history of our
organization some of our staff take
their children to work so they know they
will live or die together un security
counc Council resolutions are legally
binding but Israel which is not a member
of the council regularly flouts them as
for the US what started as unequivocal
support for Israel has turned into
growing skepticism over its tactics
we've even heard sharper language this
week from us officials but that didn't
change the US diplomatically shielding
its Ally at the UN today NE far Nasser
in Washington thanks
far there are renewed calls for the the
Israeli government to answer questions
over the perceived intelligence failure
leading to hamas's October 7th attack
the New York Times reported Israeli
officials had obtained a detailed battle
plan more than a year before the assault
that left some 12200 Israelis dead now
family members of those issuing the
warnings are speaking out Danielle hamam
Jin
reports so Maya didn't survive Noah
didn't survive shakov didn't survive and
my sweet Ronnie didn't
survive Sergeant Ronnie echel was 19
years old she and the other women in
this Photograph were observation
soldiers in a command room 780 M away
from Gaza her job was to monitor a 4 km
section of the Border you need to sit on
a chair and look at the screen for 4
hours you can't even drink from a bottle
you can you can't drink like that you
have to drink from a stroke
because you can't move your eyes from
the screen if there was activity near
the border Ronnie would report it and
she did lot of months before the October
7 it's not just Ronnie it's the rest of
the girls in the command room they saw
Hamas training they saw the some of the
farmers was changed it wasn't the same
people anymore they say it was an open
secret that Hamas had something in the
works they reported and basically it got
to do the Israel
intelligence we don't know what they did
with thisinformation nobody
knows then came the morning of October
7th for so many Israelis one of the most
shocking failures of that day was how
long it took the Israeli military to
respond in the words of one former
Special Forces Commander the entire
system collapsed the whole leadership of
the IDF and I know them you know I was
their commander in the past they need to
go Noam tibon has become somewhat of a
hero in Israel on that October day he
grabbed a pistol jumped in his car and
drove South he fought off Hamas
militants saved soldiers and civilians
including his own son and young
family the people especially the
intelligence they didn't listen to the
the troops the the female solders that
was watching this routine of exercise by
the Kamas and they gave warning after
warning and nobody listened to them and
they were slaughtered and kidnapped I'm
angry
I'm we we lost her we lost her
because because of
arrogant the family now think they know
what
[Applause]
happened women hiding in a command room
like this one tried to fight off Hamas
for hours one managed to escape through
a window but once the power went off the
doors wouldn't close and that was the
end it took nearly a month for the IDF
to confirm she'd been killed on the day
of the attack we have only one state we
have only the state of Israel and we
want to live here in peace with all of
our neighbors neigh the grief can be
unbearable the echel support the Israeli
military but are furious at Israeli
intelligence for failing their daughter
and her friends despite their warnings
she will never come back
home I'm still waiting for her Danielle
hamam Jin Global News
Jerusalem two Ontario men have been
charged with terrorism offenses for
allegedly recruiting and doing other
work for a Neo-Nazi group the federal
government lists the group as a
terrorist entity it's the third time
this year the RCMP has taken action
against farri extremist groups operating
in Canada David Aken joins us now David
what can you tell us about these charges
and the terror group they're accused of
belonging
to we'll need to the two men charged by
the RCMP are Matthew Alor a 28-year-old
from thoral Ontario and Christopher
nipac a 25-year-old from Toronto now a
court ban is in place that prevents us
from reporting more details about the
man but we can tell you they have both
been charged for work they are alleged
to have been doing with a group called
The atomwaffen Division now that's a
group that has been a listed Terror
entity in Canada since
2021 their narrative is uh usually
anti-immigration um anti- visible
minority um they they use buzzwords and
uh such as globalists and and so on so
forth for Jewish groups for Muslims RCMP
say that after an 18-month investigation
they executed search warrants after
which althorp was charged with several
offenses including Commission of a hate
crime offense for a terror group
participating in the activities of a
terror group counseling the commission
of a terrorism offense neac was charged
with participating in the activities of
a terror group experts say the rcmp's
increasing focus on combating far-right
terrorism in Canada has been effective
and these arrests are another example of
that the fact that that um these groups
were put on to the terror watch list was
an amazing First Step which which
allowed the police to to finally have
some some uh bite in order to combat
some of these groups the RCMP continues
to have a significant interest in Adam
wafin divisions activities in Canada and
there is concern in law enforcement
communities that Adam wafin adherence
have the ability and intent to carry out
attacks here as for all Thorp and nip
they are being held in custody and will
be in a Toronto courtroom Monday for a
special bail hearing nethan all right
David aen in Ottawa thanks David a
marathon voting session on Parliament
Hill has pushed past the 24hour
[Applause]
mark opposition conservatives delivered
on their promise to stall the
government's agenda in an effort to
force the Liberals to remove the federal
carbon pricing plan from all home
heating the conservatives promp prompted
135 votes in an effort to keep MPS
sitting in the house over the holiday
break MPS can vote virtually so many
left to attend events or sleep some
stayed put and caught up on their
reading Russian President Vladimir Putin
says he will be running for reelection
in March as he seeks a fifth term in
office the 71-year-old made the long
anticipated announcement at a military
award ceremony for soldiers who had
fought in Ukraine his reelection is
widely seen as inevitable with
crackdowns on any opposition making even
mild criticism risky a win in March
could see Putin remain president until
at least 2030 with Constitutional
Amendments giving him the chance to stay
in power until 2036 if he chooses to run
again in Toronto Baseball fans are
bracing for what could be a real catch
coming up the Superstar who could be
joining the Blue
Jays
speculation and excitement has hit fever
pitch in Canadian sports today
especially in Toronto there is huge Buzz
that baseball Phenom Shi Otani may be on
the verge of signing with the Blue Jays
Otani is a singular Talent a reigning
MVP who is both an elite hitter and an
ace pitcher Eric Sorenson is following
otani's
Journey it would be and possibly will be
the biggest most significant Sports
contract in in the history of this
country by far Shi Otani maybe the best
baseball player ever who could have
signed anywhere is reportedly close to
choosing Toronto and the Blue Jays at
the center of the deal would be a
massive contract orchestrated by the
Japanese star and Rogers Communications
the owner of the Jays the Rogers Center
and sportset as speculation exploded
fans searched for any clues online a
flight tracker identified a plane that
might be carrying Otani to Toronto later
reported he wasn't on it there's been a
lot of momentum there's been a lot of
momentum the J's general manager Ross
Atkins would say nothing and even as
baseball insiders like the MLB Network
elevated the Jays to favorites the most
Ardent Toronto sports fan would not will
not believe it till it's
confirmed I didn't say anything Otani is
sometimes called a unicorn the game's
top hitter and a top pitcher a talent so
rare the Los Angeles Dodgers were the
favorite to sign him an iconic West
Coast franchise versus Toronto cold
Northern and out of the way basketball's
kawh Leonard starred in Toronto briefly
and hockey John Tavaris came home to the
Leafs but no free agent Superstar at his
career Peak has chosen a long-term
contract in Toronto why would he come
Sports Nets Jamie Campbell it's the only
city in the major leagues outside of the
United States a unique culture and a
unique fan base how does Rogers pull off
and justify an estimated 500 to 700
million us contract first everything
around the Blue Jays br brand tickets
concessions and sports gear would go
through the roof and overnight Japanese
corporate media and tourism interests
would descend on Toronto this is an
athlete who will transcend regionality
he'll be an impact athlete from every
possible aspect of this country sh Otani
is the player any team would want though
he won't be pitching next year only
hitting after surgery on his arm but
with vlat Guerrero Jr bobett and a
strong pitching staff otani's
left-handed power would fit perfectly
Into the Blue Jays lineup if if it all
happens NE to if indeed Eric s said in
Toronto thanks Eric ahead the signs
covid-19 may be making a comeback in
Ontario this holiday
[Music]
season data out today from statistics
Canada is revealing new insight into the
effects of long-term covid-19 the report
reveals about one in nine Canadian
adults have had long covid that's 3.5
million Canadians symptoms are defined
as longterm if they persist for three
months or more and can't be explained by
anything else nearly 80% of people have
endured symptoms for more than 6 months
many say they have not received enough
treatment or support there are signs
covid-19 is running rampant once again
Ontario's Wastewater sign is more than
double what it was at this time last
year Mackenzie gray now on what you need
to
know it's turning into an unwelcome
holiday tradition covid cases on the
rise yet again in many parts of the
country we already have a very stretched
Health Care system and this adds another
stress to an already stretched Health
Care System the biggest hot spot onario
where Wastewater testing data now
suggests cases have doubled from the
same time last year and in cities like
wealth cases have hit a 2-year Peak but
doctors believe that for most Canadians
those numbers shouldn't be too
concerning if you are young and healthy
there really is little to worry about
from a CO perspective that's ICU Dr
cuajo kentang he's treated Co patients
since the start of the pandemic and
believes we're in a new covid era I do
think this is a time where this is the
time to be connected to have those
Christmas parties to connect with your
staff to be with family for family
members you may see who are elderly or
immuno compromised the same old advice
applies mask up stay home when you're
sick and keep up to date on vaccinations
but not just for covid shots for RSV and
influenza can also help stop serious
illness I'm just as concerned about the
upcoming influenza season for my
pediatric population and the ongoing RSV
season as I am about covid-19 and I
think that's true for uh most adults as
well the triple threat isn't expected to
overwhelm hospitals in Ontario
but in Quebec the health minister is
warning ERS could be full of sick
patients with limited staff due to
public sector strikes this going to be
tough it's going to be tough for the
same reason the combination of viruses
and everything doctors's advice to stay
up to date on covid vaccinations seems
to be falling on deaf years with less
than 20% of Canadians 70 or older fully
boosted Nathan Mackenzie gray reporting
tonight thanks
McKenzie Dino discoveries next how an
ancient predator stomach is providing
new insight for
[Music]
paleontologists a firstof its kind
Discovery is shedding new light on how
young dinosaurs lived millions of years
ago the fossils of a Tyrannosaur were
found in Southern Alberta and this
discovery is special because the bones
of another ancient dinosaur were
preserved in its stomach Heather urx
West on what scientists say it
means while the T-Rex in Jurassic Park
may have feasted on car
parts a Tyrannosaur actual diet was much
different back in the day and
researchers now have proof I knew right
away that you know this was a unique and
unusual Discovery because a Tyrannosaur
skeleton with prey items preserved
inside the stomach region had never been
found before the Bones the fossil first
discovered near Brooks Alberta in 2009
is that of a
Gorgosaurus that was much smaller than
the T-Rex believed to be about 5 to 7
years old it was like a teenager and it
sat in the Royal Tyrell Museum waiting
for someone to discover the secret in
its stomach the specimen was discovered
by a technician working here at the
Museum Mr Darren tanky and it's while he
was cleaning up the fossil he noticed
those little to bones that were coming
out of the rib cage yeah you can see all
the toes over there and those toe bones
were connected to two intact legs that
had once belonged to small birdlike
dinosaurs called chitty pets based on
the internal structure of the bones we
know that the prey items the the chitty
pest feet came from individuals that
were yearling so barely a year of age
the discovery offers new insight into
the hunting and feeding habits of the
teenage Tyrannosaur adults were
previously known to have Hunted Mega
herbivore horned or duck bill
dinosaurs it also proves that even after
120 years of Excavating and studying
Alberta's vast deposit of dinosaur bones
there's so much we still don't know so
it shows that the there's still many
significant discoveries to be made for
years to come the last meal of a young
Predator feeding Our Endless fascination
with these ancient beasts Heather urex
West Global News drum Alberta
and that is global national for this
Friday night I'm Nara tonight's year
Canada is the polar bear capital of the
world Churchill Manitoba thanks so much
for watching Colleen Christie will be at
the anchor desk tomorrow have a great
[Music]
night